vor einigen tagen erhält daniel einen
anruf aus der uni sein
einberufungsbescheid ist gekommen obwohl
er als student eigentlich vom wehrdienst
befreit ist in russland werden gerade
junge männer zum militärdienst
einberufen rund 135000 daniel ist gegen
den krieg oder das was sie in russland
eine militärische spezialeinheit
wie putin ist ein mörder er ist
wahnsinnig er bringt aktivisten um er
bringt politische häftlinge um er bringt
gewöhnliche menschen um er bringt uns
alle es kann doch keinen krieg geben wir
haben das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
und ihnen maskenball zum mars fliegen
wie kann es sein dass in einer welt ein
mensch lebt er zum mars fliegt und den
sozusagen erobert und einen mann der
unseren brüdern den krieg erklärt 13
daniel ist politisch aktiv immer wieder
geht er auf demonstrationen gegen den
krieg wurde sechs mal verhaftet saß zehn
tage im knast er weiß worauf er sich
einlässt und will trotzdem mit uns reden
fast ein bisschen stolz zeigte ein foto
aus der haft wohl mit vielen
oppositionellen und kritischen
journalisten die zelle teilte
ich saß hinter verschlossenen türen
hinter metalltür und mit einem
vergitterten fenster dies war wie in
einem traum dieses einsitzen
dank der haft habe ich menschen wie
sergej smirnow kennengelernt oder
dimitri muratow man kann man denn sonst
im gewöhnlichen leben dimitrij muratow
zu sehen bekommen
es sind immer mehr junge männer die in
russland nicht zur armee wollen das land
verlassen batumi in georgien eigentlich
ein urlaubsort für viele russen am
schwarzen meer casinos große
hotelanlagen manche nennen es das las
vegas des kaukasus
in den vergangenen wochen ist batumi für
viele russen zufluchtsort geworden rund
30.000 sollen bereits nach georgien
eingereist sein maxim kommt aus einem
moskauer vorort als der krieg begann
wusste er dass er in russland nicht mehr
bleiben will er hat einen eigenen
youtube kanal und wurde schon mehrfach
verhaftet wegen der teilnahme an
unerlaubten demonstrationen
gemeinsam mit seinem freund adele
organisierte er seine flucht maxime will
nicht in den krieg
ich bin kein soldat ich bin jemand der
nicht weiß wie es auf dem schlachtfeld
zu geht und was dort zu tun ist
und ich sehe keinerlei grund für eine
militärische aggression seitens der
russischen föderation und
am allerwenigsten möchte ich mit der
waffe in der hand gegen menschen
vorgehen müssen
maxime war ein jahr lang beim wehrdienst
seitdem hat er keine hohe meinung von
der russischen armee
man muss sich klarmachen dass die
russische regierung lügt ohne ende
ich habe meinen wehrdienst abgeleistet
und ein jahr gedient mir ist völlig klar
dass von der ebene der unteroffiziere
angefangen systematisch gelogen und
desinformation betrieben wird
soldaten haben keinerlei zugang zu
informationsquellen es gibt nur die
russische propaganda
und in russland dröhnt die propaganda
den ganzen tag in den nachrichten des
staatsfernsehens nur heldengeschichten
und siegesmeldungen dieser russische
soldat zeigt seine trophäe von der front
ein ukrainisches fernrohr und von den
ukrainern einen panzer erbeutet zu haben
sei doppelte freude so der russische
kommentare
die ukraine haben den panzer einfach
zurückgelassen mit kompletter bewaffnung
diese bilder darf niemand in russland
sehen ein twitter kanal der ukrainischen
armee gefallene russische soldaten
gefangen genommen entstellt die echtheit
lässt sich schwer überprüfen der krieg
der bilder der kampf um die wahrheit
tobt in den sozialen netzwerken
tatsache ist dass die russen hohe
verluste haben mittlerweile gehen
schätzungen der nato von rund 15.000
gefallenen oder gefangen genommenen
russischen soldaten aus
bei den bildern von butscher spricht das
russische verteidigungsministerium
von fälschung und inszenierung
als die grausamen bilder um die welt
gehen gibt es demonstrationen in einigen
russischen städten so wie hier in moskau
landesweit 215 verhaftungen es sind
nicht mehr viele die öffentlich
widerstand wagen
ortstermin am moskauer galinski gericht
daniel war am wochenende auf einer
verbotenen demonstration wurde gleich
festgenommen 48 stunden
untersuchungshaft wir treffen ihn mit
freundin polina kurz vor der verhandlung
wahrscheinlich wird man eine strafe
verhängen um die 20 bis 30 tausend rubel
dass mich das erste mal ist ja warten
also nichts neues
daniel will nicht ausreisen will weiter
protestieren will das system putin von
innen bekämpfen
nun wie können sich meine pläne ändern
wenn dies hier mein land ist ich hier
meine verwandten und freunde habe als
ich gestern auf freien fuß kam und die
fotos aus butter sei da habe ich
begriffen dass das zu viel ist dass man
uns das ganz bestimmt nicht verzeihen
wird
nach ein paar stunden kommt daniels
urteil 10.000 rubel rund 100 euro strafe
noch einmal mit einem blauen auge davon
gekommen das nächste mal droht ihm
allerdings eine lange haft